il est évident maintenant que le Parti
libéral
formera un gouvernement majoritaire en
1970 Robert Bourassin plus jeune premier
ministre du Québec de l'histoire est au
pouvoir depuis quelques mois quand
éclate la crise d'octobre les
enlèvements du FLQ et la loi des mesures
de guerre qui l'a demandé à Ottawa à
cela s'ajoute les tensions avec le
fédéral sur la constitution et la guerre
au front commun des syndicats dont il
emprisonne les billets il navigue de
crise en crise et malgré tout il demeure
très populaire les gens vivaient encore
la crête des événements d'octobre et des
tensions créées dans le pays à partir de
ça puis voulait beaucoup de stabilité il
y avait tout ça qui jouait en faveur du
Parti libéral à l'époque
Robert Bourassa veut en profiter
convoque des élections anticipées pour
le 29 octobre 1973 pour surprendre les
parties d'opposition il y a le jeune
Parti québécois avec un chef René
l'évêque non élu l'Union nationale de
Gabriel Loubier et le parti créditiste
divan Dupuis il veut les diviser encore
plus on ne soupçonné et libéraux de
Monsieur bourrinçois d'avoir un couragés
de particulier sa présenter des
candidats un peu partout là-bas espérer
que cette opposition de du parti
créditisme divise les forces adverses et
tout ça et que ça permette aux parties
libérales de l'importer facilement
de ma victoire le soir du 29 octobre le
Parti libéral remporte 102 sièges sur
110 historique du jamais vu ce qui avait
choqué ce soir-là d'une façon c'était la
réaction de Monsieur Bourasset merci
beaucoup à tous mes collègues
sa réaction avait été plutôt froide
plutôt posée plutôt rationnel mais
c'était pas celui qui bondissait en
l'air puis on a une gigantesque victoire
historique ce qui était une victoire
historique
évidemment c'est intéressant d'avoir mes
mains quand vous êtes élu comme ça avec
92 95% des députés mais le lendemain
c'est le moins c'est moins facile
Robert Bourassa a été trop gourmand et
il le regrette et au moment on a réalisé
les entrevues je suis arrivé il
expliquera son étrange réaction dans la
série d'entrevue qu'il a accordé à
Raymond Saint-Pierre en 1977 et
rassemblé en grande partie dans
l'ouvrage les années Bourassa
mais je pouvais pas
je me souviens quand j'avais rencontré
Monsieur Wilson qui était premier
ministre britannique au funérailles de
monsieur Pompidou c'était quelques mois
vraiment l'élection et Monsieur m'avait
dit un plan de lagun mais sympathique je
dis pourquoi avec Sandy député il a
population va s'attendre à ce que tu
fasses des miracles il trouvait que
l'opposition serait trop faible vous
pouvez pas blâmer le position par
exemple provenant ralenti nos travaux
empêcher certains projets de loi de
d'évoluer ou d'être créé c'est important
pour lui d'avoir une opposition comme le
Parti québécois pour dire au reste du
pays vous voyez là il y a quand même une
menace au Québec faites attention il
faut faire des concessions faut repenser
le pays et là m'a envoyé un que le Parti
québécois avait seulement 6 siège
évidemment ça lui embête tout un
argument pour discuter avec le reste du
pays ou avec Ottawa aussi dans le livre
Robert Bourassa ajoute ceci
sur le plan personnel une telle victoire
n'est pas désagréable mais sur le plan
politique un homme public lucide est
mieux avoir en face de lui une
opposition qui partage un peu les
responsabilités et ce que je n'ai pu
réussir à la campagne électorale de 1976
c'est d'impliquer l'opposition dans le
débat les gens voyaient presque un
monopole du gouvernement et tout ça
c'est facile après d'accuser ce
gouvernement qui qui menait tout et qui
avait pas besoin de faire des
concessions évidemment on peut mettre
des accusés de de corruption et tout ça
ça c'est revenu souvent dans le des
bonnes 76 évidemment doivent être au
coeur de nos discussions en 1976 Robert
bourra sa fait face au même crise qu'en
1973 constitutionnelle linguistique
syndicale avec en prime l'hyperinflation
et une économie en difficulté j'accepte
évidemment le Verdez que la population
qui d'une opposition solide les
électeurs rendent Robert Bourassa
responsable de tous ces problèmes
ils émettent leur verdict
[Applaudissements]